des ruptures majeures pour la société
française c'est la promesse du projet de
loi climat et résilience héritage de la
convention citoyenne sur le climat l'un
des derniers textes phares du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron nos
logements notre alimentation mais aussi
nos déplacements c'est tout un ensemble
de notre vie quotidienne qui est visé
dans ce texte de 69 articles avec pour
objectif la réduction de nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'au moins 40%
en 2030 par rapport à l'année 1990 ce
texte n'a pas encore entamé son parcours
parlementaire qu'il est déjà sous le feu
des critiques
dernière en date celle émise par le haut
conseil pour le climat ce 23 février
le rapport de l'instance qui est
indépendante vise à évaluer je cite
l'ambition du projet de loi et la
pertinence de ces mesures au regard de
la stratégie nationale bas carbone une
dynamique actuelle de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
insuffisante c'est ce que souligne ce
rapport du hcc qui pointe aussi du doigt
le manque d'ambition et de porter des
mesures qui composent ce fameux projet
de loi ces mesures constitueraient donc
une part importante de l'effort a engagé
mais ne permettrait pas à la france de
rattraper son retard dans la transition
bas carbone
l'absence de transparence méthodologique
ne permet pas au hcc de s'exprimer sur
l'impact attendu du projet de loi
le 11 février dernier c'est le conseil
d'état qui a analysé ce texte ces
conclusions ne sont pas très tendres
avec le gouvernement l'instant s'ils
relèvent une analyse des impacts trop
souvent superficielle et dénonce des
insuffisances notable même son cloche du
côté de certains membres de la
commission citoyenne pour le climat le
haut conseil pour le climat appelle donc
le gouvernement à rectifier le tir
l'examen du texte par le parlement devra
permettre de compléter et améliorer la
portée des mesures proposées y compris
sur le pilotage et la conduite de la
transition pour que les objectifs
annoncés soit atteint sachez que le
projet de loi climat et résilience
arrivera donc entre les mains des
parlementaires le 10 mars prochain